fauci threw a bad pitch and now
everyone's goofing on gary again
michael wouldn't you agree though that
fouchy's pitch was even worse than
gary's
fouchy's 79 um okay he's
obviously done a lot for the country
he's under duress right now
okay he threw his pitch out so at first
tony fauci
it starts trending number one and then
five ten maybe fifteen minutes later
baba bowie
starts trending number one in the
country and
after a week of you know riots in
portland
all the things we're dealing with with
covid to go into the weekend
with baba bowie trending the [ __ ]
joy that that brought me and i'm sure it
brought the rest
of the country any it was just a great
[ __ ] thing and then we're seeing the
old videos surface we basically relived
the pitch and
as much as i pound that [ __ ] ape
howard
as much as i i get on him about those
big [ __ ] teeth
and everything that comes with baba
bowie i just
appreciate this man so much you know
you're great
robin's great but bowie buffy is the
real mvp
well you know you're making the point
that even during a global pandemic
this would not stop people from goofing
on gary's pitch
and uh you got to be amazed by that
you're absolutely right
gary was trending number one gary when
you saw fauci's pitch
did you feel like like spidey sense did
you get a tingling all over your body
saying
uh oh i know what's coming next well i
wasn't watching the game
so mary and i are hanging out having a
drink outside you know and then uh
of a sudden my phone starts blowing up
and uh everybody's big thing to me
is good news gary you're off the hook
but of course i'm not you in their mind
somebody threw a worst pitcher
off the hook but all it really means is
every time this pitch happens it's like
groundhog's day
it just all starts all over again this
game was so highly anticipated that it
was one of the highest rated games so
not only was uh fauci's pitch viewed by
you know millions and millions of people
but then gary
played that this is what uh michael's
talking about here it is on national
television
espn's telecast of opening night
baseball is presented by john deere
nothing runs like a deer
run with us dr anthony fauci
just a bit outside that was uh that was
baba booey-esque
it broke the record for most people
watching an opening day baseball game
which was like four million
wow and all of a sudden half the country
probably goes what the [ __ ] is baba
bowie
oh they know no no no gary they [ __ ]
know
i mean and by the way i should mention
this too this will make you happy too
michael
gary was mentioned by joe buck
the ball slipped out during a pitch and
he even mentioned gary listen to this
this is a whole different way
and this one just slipped out of the
hand of harper
down to second is the runner estrada
that looked like a ceremonial first
pitch
somewhere gary de la bate is smiling
and 50 cent and everybody else who's on
the list
the list joseon's joe sends me an email
afterwards like hey gave you a shout out
and i'm like am i supposed to go with
thank you thank you thank you for
goofing
all right michael you make a good point
gary has trended number one it's the
shitty pitch list and gary's right on
the top
you